well guess what we're going to kick off
the show today with a little
drew's news it's the baked potato of
news program
piled high with good news fixings and
with me at the desk
is my news bud who really knows how to
dress his spud it's rusty ross matthew
i'm a fully loaded tater you are a
totally loaded tater
is there anything better than a fully
loaded baked potato
i like to butter the potato and like
wish it all around and like get it all
mushed up
and then attack then the sour cream then
the cheese and the bacon bit then the
chive
so much chives so many chives so many
tribes oh my god well i'm excited about
our first story rafi
uh this is the story of all stories
we've been talking about this since we
first heard about it
we really did we latched right on
like a baby uh to the sex and the city
reboot there's some fresh news out w
magazine
reports that while samantha won't be
back the show has announced plans to add
three
new friends to the group they are all
women of color
and they say well just like in real life
some friendships
fade as new ones grow and bloom in the
garden and they've also confirmed
that aiden will be back i happen to have
been a fan of aiden i love when he says
the
the flaws the best part you know
listen here's the deal i'm excited there
will be new friends because we're still
mourning samantha i love that there's
going to be diversity on the show yeah
but
bottom line i need to know what carrie's
doing and i need to know about
uh miranda and charlotte that's all i
want the rest great i'm happy
you know it's like at a buffet here we
go with the buffet
i love it you want your mains and then
you can have side dishes as well but i
i need my main dishes i i agree
i have a theory i've never expressed
this theory before but can i talk it out
with you
i would love to hear it all four of the
women from sex in the city are really
just
one woman like all the parts of one
person
as we are all part of that i completely
agree i think that's why
there were different times in my life i
felt like a carry there were different
times in my life i felt like a miranda a
samantha
i was like oh my god i'm like becoming a
charlotte york which i did not
anticipate
who are you today just out of curiosity
carrie yeah well i'm uh um i'm a miranda
because i'm all business today with a
samantha top note because i have a date
later okay
tmi no it isn't i
love that you like i love that you know
i'm taking
all right uh okay well this story is for
singles out there who are ready for
their own
personal sex in the city summer get
ready
stylist reports the latest dating trend
is
honesty bombing this is fascinating
honesty bombing is
it means showing up to a date and being
100
real and honest about who you are and
what you want without any apologies
basically everyone's sick of wasting
time right playing games so they're
going to get to the point
nice to meet you now i want kids do you
have
you know what's your fica score i want
to know it all i think this
is a terrible idea really
i do what's more intimidating than sit
down nice to meet you
what's your future plans your 10-year
plan that's a that's a nightmare
i i want to like i want to peel you like
an onion i want to get to know
you take my time i don't scare you away
what i
am excited about with this is not like
here's where i'm at this is what i want
but just not faking who you are
well yes honesty bombing if it can be in
the form of
like i'm going to really let you know
who i am
maybe the not where i'm at and what i
want
but the who i am bring it on i want to
know who i'm dealing with
i don't want the pretenses i i i think
that honesty bombing
um if it was more in a personality sense
could be really cool yeah uh-huh mm-hmm
okay fair enough i'm going to say
rossi tell me right now if you're gonna
if you're gonna try to sell a car you're
gonna wash the car before you put the
for sale sign in am i right
ryan this is what i'm saying yeah so you
gotta sort of be like the best version
of yourself that day but i just don't
like the idea of honesty bombing
all at once is too much to take honestly
revealing
okay is a better plan so you want a
softer landing
yeah let's just like don't freak me out
man i just met you
i hear you got it i do i do well
in the ongoing battle to detach our
eyeballs from the
glowy rectangles we're all addicted to
you
traveling leisure reports that a company
is going to pay you 692
a month to quit instagram
i am in love with the story it is so fun
okay
you have to use the time that you would
spend
scrolling to learn a new skill instead
and the company is called
how now it's a new learning platform and
you can apply
on their website so for three months
what they're going to do is they're
going to track your progress to see how
much you can learn
in about an hour a day which they say is
the average time
an adult in the uk spends on instagram i
think i just learned the difference
between the uk and america
um okay ross could you quit instagram
and if you did
what skill would you want to learn for
starters no i don't want it no
you know what i like doing instagram
that is like my thing at the end of the
day where i just want
in the end the middle of the day in the
beginning of the day i just like just to
scroll it and i understand that i should
be learning new skills but i
am exhausted all right i've already
learned what i want to learn
you know what i want to learn what
barefoot contessa's doing now
okay what kim kardashian's doing now
that's all that i have
room for left in here now but now i do
feel lazy that i don't want to learn a
new skill
i don't i think that you made a really
salient argument and you should feel
good about it well i'm going to google
what salient means and get back to you
well we've got all the news that makes
you go yum
because it's time for food all right
this comes to us
from eater and by the way if you're on
instagram and you're not on eater
get on it because it's one of my
favorite accounts i'm gonna follow right
now i don't follow them yet oh
it'll change your life somebody get my
phone i'll follow him at the commercial
i'll probably okay well the mad
scientist
at jenny's ice cream they made an
everything
bagel ice cream okay we are we are big
fans of everything bagel we have tried
chips
for the the seasoning is so good
ice cream i don't know well um this
really is
you know what it sounds like cream
cheese ice cream with poppy seeds sesame
seeds garlic bits of onions
um this also might be like you know
a treat for on 420 if you know what i
mean
okay let's try it hold on
okay i'm not gonna lie
to you at first i was like
yes and then i was no and now i'm like
yes it's a roller coaster
this is delicious i just do not
recommend eating this on a date
because you talk about a bomb your
breasts i don't recommend eating this on
420 or you're going to eat the entire
pipe
[Music]
you